The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So we said that the task
of statistical mechanics
is to assign probabilities to
different microstates given
that we have knowledge
of the microstate.
And the most kind of simple
logical place to start
was in the
microcanonical ensemble
where the microstate
that we specified
was one in which there was
no exchange of work or heat
with the surroundings so
that the energy was constant,
and the parameters,
such as x and N,
that account for chemical
and mechanical work
were fixed also.
Then this assignment
was, we said,
like counting how many
faces the dice has,
and saying all of them
are equally likely.
So we would say that
the probability here
of a microstate is of
the form 0 or 1 depending
on whether the energy
of that microstate
is or is not the right energy
that is listed over here.
And as any probability,
it has to be normalized.
So we had this 1 over omega.
And we also had a rule for
converting probabilities
to entropies, which in
dimensionless form-- that
is, if we divide by kB-- was
simply minus the expectation
value of the log of the
probability, this probability
being uniformly 1 over omega.
This simply gave us
log of omega E, x, N.
Once we had the entropy
as a function of E, x, N,
we also identified the
derivatives of this quantity
in equilibrium.
And partial derivative
with respect to energy
was identified as
1 So systems that
were in equilibrium with each
other, this derivative dS by dE
had to be the same
for all of them.
And because of
mechanical stability,
we could identify the next
derivative with respect to x.
That was minus J/T.
And with respect to N
by identifying a corresponding
thing, we would get this.
So from here, we can
proceed and calculate
thermodynamic properties using
these microscopic rules, as
well as probabilities in the
entire space of microstates
that you have.
Now, the next thing
that we did was
to go and look at the
different ensemble,
the canonical ensemble,
in which we said that,
again, thermodynamically,
I choose
a different set of variables.
For example, I can replace
the energy with temperature.
And indeed, the characteristic
of the canonical ensemble
is that rather than
specifying the energy,
you specify the temperature.
But there's still no
chemical or mechanical work.
So the other two parameters
are kept fixed also.
And then the
statement that we had
was that by putting a system in
contact with a huge reservoir,
we could ensure that it is
maintained at some temperature.
And since system and reservoir
were jointly microcanonical,
we could use the probabilities
that we had microcanonically.
We integrated over the degrees
of freedom of the reservoir
that we didn't care about.
And we ended up
with the probability
of a microstate in the
canonical ensemble, which
was related to
the energy of that
by the form exponential of minus
beta h where we introduced beta
to be 1 over kT.
And this probably, again,
had to be normalized.
So the normalization
we called Z. And Z
is attained by summing over
all of the microstates E
to the minus beta H of the
microstate where this could
be an integration over
the entire phase space
if you're dealing with
continuous variables.
OK, now the question
was, thermodynamically,
these quantities T
and E are completely
exchangeable ways of
identifying the same equilibrium
state, whereas what
I have done now
is I have told you what
the temperature is.
But the energy of the
system is a random variable.
And so I can ask, what
is the probability
that I look at my system and
I find a particular energy E?
So how can I get that?
Well, that probability,
first of all,
has to come from a microstate
that has the right energy.
And so I will get
e to the minus beta
E divided by Z, which is
the probability of getting
that microstate that
has the right energy.
But I only said something
about the energy.
And there are a huge number
of microstates, as we've seen,
that have the same energy.
So I could have picked from
any one of those microstates,
their number being omega
of E, the omega that we
had identified before.
So since omega can be
written as exponential of s
over kB, this you can
also think of as being
proportional to exponential
of minus beta E minus T,
the entropy that I would
get for that energy
according to the formula
above, divided by Z.
Now, we said that
the quantity that I'm
looking at here in
the numerator has
a dependence on the size of
the system that is extensive.
Both the entropy
and energy we expect
to be growing proportionately
to the size of the system.
And hence, this exponent
also grows proportionately
to the size of the system.
So I expect that if I
plot this probability
as a function of energy, this
probability to get energy E,
it would be one of
those functions.
It's certainly positive.
It's a probability.
It has an exponential
dependence.
So there's a part that maybe
from the density of states
grows exponentially.
e to the minus beta E
will exponential kill it.
And maybe there is, because
of this competition,
one or potentially more maxima.
But if there are more maxima
locally, I don't really care.
Because one will be
exponentially larger
than the other.
So presumably, there is
some location corresponding
to some E star where the
probability is maximized.
Well, how should I characterize
the energy of the system?
Should I pick E star, or
given this probability,
should I look at maybe the
mean value, the average of H?
How can I get the average of H?
Well, what I need to do is to
sum over all the microstates H
of the microstate
e to the minus beta
H divided by sum over
microstates e to the minus beta
H, which is the normalization.
The denominator is of course
the partition function.
The numerator can be obtained
by taking a derivative of this
with respect to beta
of the minus sign.
So what this is is minus
the log Z by d beta.
So if I have calculated
H, I can potentially
go through this procedure
and maybe calculate
where the mean value is.
And is that a better
representation
of the energy of the system than
the most likely value, which
was E star?
Well, let's see how
much energy fluctuates.
Basically, we saw that if
I repeat this procedure
many times, I can see that
the n-th moment is minus 1
to the n 1 over Z the
n-th derivative of Z
with respect to beta.
And hence the
partition function,
by expanding it
in powers of beta,
will generate for me
higher and higher moments.
And we therefore concluded that
the cumulant would be obtained
by the same procedure, except
that I will replace this
by log Z. So this will
be the n-th derivative
of log Z with respect to beta.
So the variance H squared
c is a second derivative
of log Z. The first
derivative gives me
the first cumulant,
which was the mean.
So this is going to
give me d by d beta
with a minus sign of the
expectation value of H,
which is the same
thing as kBT squared,
because the derivative
of 1 over kT
is 1 over T squared times
derivative with respect to T.
And it goes to the other
side, to the numerator.
And so then I have
the derivative
of this object with
respect to temperature,
which is something
like a heat capacity.
But most importantly,
the statement
is that all of
these quantities are
things that are of the order
of the size of the system.
And just like we did in
the central limit theorem,
with the addition
of random variables,
you have a situation that
is very much like that.
The distribution,
in some sense, is
going to converge more and more
towards the Gaussian dominated
by the first and
second cumulant.
And in fact, even the
second cumulant we see
is of the order of
square root of n.
And hence the fluctuations
between these two quantities,
which are each one
of them order of n,
is only of the order
of square root of n.
And when the limit of
n goes to infinity,
we can ignore any
such difference.
We can essentially
identify either one of them
with the energy of the
system thermodynamically.
And then this
quantity, if I identify
this with energy of
the system, is simply
the usual heat
capacity of constant x.
So the scale of the
fluctuations over here
is set by square root of kBT
squared the heat capacity.
By the way, which
is also the reason
that heat capacities
must be positive.
Because statistically,
the variances
are certainly
positive quantities.
So you have a
constraint that we had
seen before on the
sign emerging in
its statistical interpretation.
What I did over here was to
identify an entropy associated
with a particular form
of the probability.
What happens if I look at an
entropy with this probability
that I have over here?
OK, so this is a
probability phase space.
What is its entropy?
So S over k is expectation
value of log p.
And what is log of p?
Well, there is log of this minus
beta H. So what I will have,
because of the change in sign--
beta expectation value of H.
And then I have
minus log Z here.
The sign changes, and
I will get plus log Z.
So yeah, that's correct.
If I were to rearrange
this, what do I get?
I can take this
minus-- let's see.
Yeah, OK, so if I take
this to the other side,
then I will get
that log Z equals--
this goes to the other
side-- minus beta.
Expectation value of
H we are calling E.
And then I have
multiplying this by beta.
The kB's disappear, and
I will get minus TS.
So we see that I can identify
log Z with the combination E
minus TS, which is the
Helmholtz free energy.
So log Z, in the same way that
the normalization here that
was omega, gave us the entropy.
The normalization
of the probability
in the canonical ensemble, which
is also called the partition
function if I take its log,
will give me the free energy.
And I can then go and
compute various thermodynamic
quantities based on that.
There's an alternative way of
getting the same result, which
is to note that actually the
same quantity is appearing over
here, right?
And really, I should be
evaluating the probability here
at the maximum.
Maximum is the
energy of the system.
So if you like, I can call this
variable over here epsilon.
This is the
probability of epsilon.
And it is only when
I'm at the maximum
that I can replace this epsilon
with E. Then since with almost
probability 1, I'm
going to see this state
and none of the
other states, because
of this exponential dependence.
When this expression is
evaluated at this energy,
it should give me probability 1.
And so you can see again that
Z has to be-- so basically what
I'm saying is that
this quantity has
to be 1 so that you get
this relationship back
from that perspective also.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I agree
that if in order
to plug in d, mean energy,
into that expression,
you would get a probability
of 1 at that point.
But because even though
the other energies are
exponentially less probable,
they strictly speaking
aren't 0 probability, are they?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: So how does
this get normalized?
How does this probability
expression get normalized?
PROFESSOR: OK, so
what are we doing?
So Z, I can also write it as
the normalization of the energy.
So rather than picking the one
energy that maximizes things,
you say, you should
really do this, right?
Now, I will evaluate this
by the saddle point method.
The saddle point method says,
pick the maximum of this.
So I have e to the minus beta
F evaluated at the maximum.
And then I have
to integrate over
variations around that maximum.
Variations around
that maximum I have
to expand this to second order.
And if I really correctly
expand this to second order,
I will get delta E squared
divided by this 2kTCx,
because we already established
what this variance is.
I can do this
Gaussian integration.
I get e to the minus
beta F of e star.
And then the variance
of this object
is going to give me root of
2 pi kTC of x-- T-square.
So what do I mean when I
say that this quantity is Z?
Really, the thing that we are
calculating always in order
to make computation is
something like a free energy,
which is log Z.
So when I take the
log, log of Z is
going to be this minus beta
F star S. But you're right.
There was a weight.
All of those things
are contributing.
How much are they contributing?
1/2 log of 2 pi kBT squared C.
Now, in the limit
of large N, this
is order of N. This is order
of log N. And I [INAUDIBLE].
So it's the same saddle point.
The idea of saddle point
was that there is a weight.
But you can ignore it.
There maybe another
maximum here.
You say, what about that?
Well, that will be
exponentially small.
So everything I keep emphasizing
only works because of this N
goes to infinity limit.
And it's magical, you see?
You can replace this sum
with just one, the maximum.
And everything is
fine and consistent.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Not to
belabor this point,
but if you have an expected
return for catastrophe where
this outlier causes an event
that brings the system down,
couldn't that chase this limit
in the sense that as that goes
to 0, that still
goes to infinity,
and thus you're-- you
understand what I'm saying.
If an outlier causes this
simulation-- that's my word--
causes this system to crumble,
then-- so is there a paradox
there?
PROFESSOR: No, there
is here the possibility
of a catastrophe in the
sense that all the oxygen
in this room could
go over there,
and you and I will suffocate
after a few minutes.
It's possible, that's true.
You just have to
wait many, many ages
of the universe
for that to happen.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So when
you're integrating,
that introduces units
into the problem.
So we have to divide by
something to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, and
when we are doing
this for the case
of the ideal gas,
I will be very
careful to do that.
But it turns out
that those issues,
as far as various
derivatives are concerned,
will not make too
much difference.
But when we are looking
at the specific example,
such as the ideal gas, I
will be careful about that.
So we saw how this
transition occurs.
But when we were
looking at the case
of thermodynamical
descriptions, we
looked at a couple
of other microstates.
One of them was the
Gibbs canonical.
And what we did
was we said, well,
let's allow now some
work to take place
on the system, mechanical work.
And rather than saying
that, say, the displacement
x is fixed, I allow it to vary.
But I will say what the
corresponding force is.
But let's keep the number
of particles fixed.
So essentially, the
picture that we have
is that somehow my system is
parametrized by some quantity
x.
And I'm maintaining the system
at fixed value of some force J.
So x is allowed potentially
to find the value that
is consistent with
this particular J
that I impose on the system.
And again, I have put the
whole system in contact
with the reservoir
temperature T so
that if I now say
that I really maintain
the system at
variable x, but fix J,
I have to put this
spring over there.
And then this spring
plus the system
is jointly in a
canonical perspective.
And what that really
means is that you
have to keep track of the
energy of the microstate,
as well as the energy that
you extract from the spring,
which is something like J dot x.
And since the joint system
is in the canonical state,
it would say that
the probability
for the joint system, which
has T and J and N specified,
but I don't know the
microstate, and I
don't know the actual
displacement x,
this joint probability
is canonical.
And so it is proportional
to e to the minus beta
H of the microstate plus
this contribution Jx
that I'm getting from the
other degree of freedom, which
is the spring, which keeps
the whole thing at fixed J.
And I have to divide by
some normalization that
in addition includes
integration over x.
And this will depend on T, J, N.
So in this system, both x
and the energy of the system
are variables.
They can potentially change.
What I can now do is to either
characterize like I did over
here what the probability of x
is, or go by this other route
and calculate what the
entropy of this probability
is, which would be minus
the log of the corresponding
probability.
And what is the
log in this case?
I will get beta
expectation value of H.
And I will get minus beta
J expectation value of x.
And then I will get plus
log of this Z tilde.
So rearranging things, what I
get is that log of this Z tilde
is minus beta.
I will call this E
like I did over there.
Minus J-- I would call this
the actual thermodynamic
displacement x.
And from down here,
the other side,
I will get a factor of TS.
So this should
remind you that we
had called a Gibbs free
energy the combination
of E minus TS minus Jx.
And the natural
variables for this G
were indeed, once we
looked at the variation
DE, T. They were J, and N that
we did not do anything with.
And to the question of, what
is the displacement, since it's
a random variable
now, I can again
try to go to the same
procedure as I did over here.
I can calculate the
expectation value
of x by noting that
this exponent here
has a factor of beta Jx.
So if I take a derivative
with respect to beta J,
I will bring down a factor of x.
So if I take the derivative
of log of this Z tilde
with respect to beta
J, I would generate
what the mean value is.
And actually, maybe
here let me show you
that dG was indeed
what I expected.
So dG would be dE.
dE has a TdS.
This will make that
into a minus SdT.
dE has a Jdx.
This will make it minus xdJ.
And then I have mu dN.
So thermodynamically,
you would have
said that x is obtained
as a derivative of G
with respect to J.
Now, log Z is something
that is like beta
G. At fixed temperature,
I can remove these betas.
What do I get?
This is the same
thing as dG by dJ.
And I seem to have
lost a sign somewhere.
OK, log Z was minus G.
So there's a minus here.
Everything is consistent.
So you can play around with
things in multiple ways,
convince yourself, again,
that in this ensemble,
I have fixed the
force, x's variable.
But just like the energy
here was well defined up
to something that
was square root of N,
this x is well defined
up to something
that is of the order
square root of N.
Because again, you can
second look at the variance.
It will be related to two
derivatives of log G, which
would be related to
one derivative of x.
And ultimately,
that will give you
something like, again,
kBT squared d of x by dJ.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you mention
again, regarding the probability
distribution?
What was the idea?
PROFESSOR: How did I
get this probability?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK, so I
said that canonically, I
was looking at a system
where x was fixed.
But now I have
told you that J-- I
know what J is,
what the force is.
And so how can I make
sure that the system
is maintained at a fixed J?
I go back and say,
how did I ensure
that my microcanonical system
was at a fixed temperature?
I put it in contact
with a huge bath
that had the right temperature.
So here, what I
will do is I will
connect the wall of my
system to a huge spring that
will maintain a particle
[? effect ?] force
J on the system.
When we do it for
the case of the gas,
I will imagine
that I have a box.
I have a piston on top
that can move up and down.
I put a weight on top of it.
And that weight will
ensure that the pressure
is at some particular
value inside the gas.
But then the piston
can slide up and down.
So a particular
state of the system
I have to specify where the
piston is, how big x is,
and what is the
microstate of the system.
So the variables that I'm
not sure of are mu and x.
Now, once I have said
what mu and x is, and I've
put the system in contact
with a bath at temperature T,
I can say, OK, the whole
thing is canonical,
the energy of the entire system
composed of the energy of this,
which is H of mu, and the energy
of the spring, which is Jx.
And so the canonical
probability for the joint system
is composed of the
net energy of the two.
And I have to normalize it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are you
taking x squared
to be a scalar, so
that way the dx over dJ
is like a divergence?
Or are you taking it to
be a covariance tensor?
PROFESSOR: Here, I have
assumed that it is a scalar.
But we can certainly do-- if
you want to do it with a vector,
then I can say something
about positivity.
So I really wanted this to
be a variance and positive.
And so if you like, then it
would be the diagonal terms
of whatever
compressibility you have.
So you certainly can generalize
this expression to be a vector.
You can have xI xJ, and you
would have d of xI with respect
to JJ or something like this.
But here, I really
wanted the scalar case.
Everything I did was
scalar manipulation.
And this is now the variance
of something and is positive.
OK, there was one
other ensemble,
which was the grand canonical.
So here, I went from the
energy to temperature.
I kept N fixed.
I didn't make it into
a chemical potential.
But I can do that.
Rather than having
fixed number, I
can have fixed
chemical potential.
But then I can't allow
the other variable
to be J. It has to be x.
Because as we have discussed
many times, at least one
of them has to be extensive.
And then you can follow this
procedure that you had here.
Chemical work is just an
analog of mechanical work
mathematically.
So now I would have
the probability
that I have specified
this set of variables.
But now I don't know
what my microstate is.
Actually, let me put mu s.
Because I introduced a
chemical potential mu.
So mu sub s is the
microstate of the system.
I don't know how many particles
are in that microstate.
The definition of mu s
would potentially cover N.
Or I can write it explicitly.
And then, what I will have is
e to the beta mu N minus beta
H of the microstate's
energy divided
by the normalization, which is
the grand partition function
Q. So this was the Gibbs
partition function.
This is a function of T, x
at the chemical potential.
And the analog of all of these
expressions here would exist.
So the average
number in the system,
which now we can use as
the thermodynamic number,
as we've seen, would be d of log
of Q with respect to d beta mu.
And you can look at the
variances, et cetera.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So do
you define, then,
what the microstate
of the system
really is if the particle
number is [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's say
I have five particles or six
particles in the system.
It would be, in the
first case, the momentum
coordinates of five particles.
In the next case,
in the momentum,
I have coordinates
of six particles.
So these are spaces,
as it has changed,
where the dimensionality
of the phase space
is also being modified.
And again, for the ideal gas, we
will explicitly calculate that.
And again, you can identify what
the log of this grand partition
is going to be.
It is going to be
minus beta E minus TS.
Rather than minus Jx,
it will be minus mu N.
And this combination is what
we call the grand potential g,
which is E minus TS minus mu
N. You can do thermodynamics.
You can do probability.
Essentially, in the
large end limit, and only
in the large end limit, there's
a consistent identification
of most likely states according
to the statistical description
and thermodynamic parameters.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can one build a more
general ensemble or description
where, say, J is
not a fixed number,
but I know how it varies?
I know that it's subject to--
say the spring is not exactly
a Hookean spring.
It's not linear.
The proportion is not linear.
PROFESSOR: I think you are then
describing a [? composing ?]
system, right?
Because it may be
that your system
itself has some
nonlinear properties
for its force as a
function of displacement.
And most generally, it will.
Very soon, we will
look at the pressure
of a gas, which will be
some complicated function
of its density-- does not
necessarily have to be linear.
So the system itself
could have all kinds
of nonlinear dependencies.
But you calculate the
corresponding force
through this procedure.
And it will vary in some
nonlinear function of density.
If you're asking,
can I do something
in which I couple this
to another system, which
has some nonlinear
properties, then I
would say that really
what you're doing
is you're putting
two systems together.
And you should be doing separate
thermodynamical calculations
for each system, and
then put the constraint
that the J of this
system should equal
the J of the other system.
AUDIENCE: I don't think that's
quite what I'm getting at.
I'm thinking here,
the J is not given
by another
thermodynamical system.
We're just applying
it-- like we're not
applying thermodynamics to
whatever is asserting to J.
PROFESSOR: No, I'm trying
to mimic thermodynamics.
So in thermodynamics,
I have a way
of describing
equilibrium systems
in terms of a certain
set of variables.
And given that set of variables,
there are conjugate variables.
So I'm constructing
something that
is analogous to thermodynamics.
It may be that you want
to do something else.
And my perspective
is that the best way
to do something else
is to sort of imagine
different systems that are
in contact with each other.
Each one of them you
do thermodynamics,
and then you put
equilibrium between them.
If I want to solve
some complicated system
mechanically, then I sort of
break it down into the forces
that are acting on one, forces
that are acting on the other,
and then how this
one is responding,
how that one is responding.
I don't see any
advantage to having
a more complicated
mechanical description
of an individual system.
AUDIENCE: It's not
like in reality.
It's hard to obtain
situations where
the external force is fixed.
Really, if we're doing
an experiment here,
the pressure in the
atmosphere is a fixed number.
But maybe in other
circumstances--
PROFESSOR: Yes, so if you
are in another circumstance,
like you have one gas that
is expanding in a nonlinear
medium, then what
I would do is I
would calculate
the pressure of gas
as a function of its
volume, et cetera.
I would calculate the
response of that medium
as a function of
stress, or whatever
else I'm exerting on that.
And I say that I am constrained
to move around the trajectory
where this force
equals this force.
So now let's carry out this
procedure for the ideal gas.
And the microscopic
description of the ideal gas
was that I have to sum over--
its Hamiltonian is composed
of the kinetic energies
of the particles.
So I have their momentum.
Plus the potential that we
said I'm going to assume
describes box of volume mu.
And it is ideal,
because we don't
have interactions
among particles.
We will put that shortly
for the next version.
Now, given this,
I can go through
the various prescriptions.
I can go
microcanonically and say
that I know the energy volume
and the number of particles.
And in this prescription,
we said that the probability
is either 0 or 1
divided by omega.
And this is if qi not
in box and sum over i Pi
squared over 2m not equal
to E and one otherwise.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any reason why
we don't use a
direct delta there?
PROFESSOR: I don't
know how to use
the direct delta
for reading a box.
For the energy,
the reason I don't
like to do that is because
direct deltas have dimensions
of 1 over whatever
thing is inside.
Yeah, you could do that.
It's just I prefer not to do it.
But you certainly could do that.
It is certainly
something that is
0 or 1 over omega
on that surface.
The S for this, what was it?
It was obtained by
integrating over
the entirety of the 6N
dimensional phase space.
From the Q integrations,
we got V to the N.
From the momentum
integrations, we
got the surface area of
this hypersphere, which
was 2 pi to the 3N over 2,
because it was 3N dimensional.
And this was the solid angle.
And then we got
the radius, which
is 2mE square root raised
to the power of number
of dimensions minus 1.
Then we did something else.
We said that the phase space
is more appropriately divided
by N factorial for
identical particles.
Here, I introduced
some factor of H
to dimensionalize the
integrations over PQ space
so that this quantity now
did not carry any dimensions.
And oops, this was
not S. This was omega.
And S/k, which
was log of omega--
we took the log of
that expression.
We got N log of V. From
the log of N factorial,
Stirling's approximation
gave us a factor of N over e.
All of the other factors were
proportional to 3N over 2.
So the N is out front.
I will have a factor
of 3 over 2 here.
I have 2 pi mE
divided by 3N over 2.
And then there's E from
Stirling's approximation.
And that was the entropy
of the ideal gas.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does that
N factorial change
when describing the system
with distinct particles?
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
AUDIENCE: So that
definition changes?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so
this factor of-- if I
have a mixture of gas, and
one of them are one kind,
and two of them
are another kind,
I would be dividing by N1
factorial, N2 factorial,
and not by N1 plus N2 factorial.
AUDIENCE: So that is the correct
definition for all the cases?
PROFESSOR: That's the
definition for phase space
of identical particles.
So all of them are
identical particle,
is what I have written.
All of them are distinct.
There's no such factor.
If half of them are of one type
and identical, half of them
are another type
of identical, then
I will have N over 2
factorial, N over 2 factorial.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when you're
writing the formula for number
of microstates, just a
question of dimensions.
You write V to the
N. It gives you
something that mentions
coordinate to the power
3N times something of
dimensions of [INAUDIBLE].
The power is 3N minus
1 divided by H to 3N.
So overall, this gives
you 1 over momentum.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's put a delta
E over here-- actually, not
a delta E, but a delta
R. OK, so now it's fine.
It's really what I
want to make sure is
that the extensive part is
correctly taken into account.
I may be missing a
factor of dimension
that is of the order of
1 every now and then.
And then you can put some
[INAUDIBLE] to correct it.
And it's, again, the
same story of the orange.
It's all in the
skin, including--
so the volume is the same
thing as the surface area,
which is essentially
what I'm-- OK?
So once you have this, you can
calculate various quantities.
Again, the S is dE over T plus
PdV over T minus mu dN over T.
So you can immediately
identify, for example,
that 1 over T derivative
with respect to energy
would give me a factor
of N/E. If I take
a derivative with respect
to volume, P over T,
derivative of this object
with respect to volume
will give me N over V.
And mu over T is--
oops, actually,
in all of these cases,
I forgot the kB.
So I have to restore it.
And here I would get kB
log of the N out front.
I can throw out V/N
4 pi m E over 3N.
And I forgot the H's.
So the H's would appear
as an H squared here.
They will appear as an H squared
here raised to the 3/2 power.
We also said that I can
look at the probability
of a single particle
having momentum P1.
And we showed that
essentially I have
to integrate over everything
else if I'm not interested,
such as the volume of
the particle number one.
The normalization was omega
E, V, N. And integrating
over particles numbers
two to N, where
the energy that
is left to them is
E minus the kinetic energy
of the one particle,
gave me this expression.
And essentially,
we found that this
was proportional to one
side divided by E. 1
minus P1 squared over 2m raised
to the power that was very
close to 3N over 2
minus/plus something,
and that this was
proportional, therefore,
to this P1 squared
over 2m times-- P1
squared 2mE-- 3N over 2E.
And 3N over 2E from here we see
is the same thing as 1 over kT.
So we can, with
this prescription,
calculate all of the
properties of the ideal gas,
including probability to see
one particle with some momentum.
Now, if I do the same thing in
the canonical form, in which
the microstate that I'm
looking at is temperature,
volume, number of
particles, then
the probability of
a microstate, given
that I've specified
now the temperature,
is proportional to the energy
of that microstate, which
is e to the minus beta sum
over i Pi squared over 2m.
Of course I would have to
have all of Qi's in box.
Certainly they cannot
go outside the box.
And this has to be normalized.
Now we can see that in
this canonical ensemble,
the result that we had to do
a couple of lines of algebra
to get, which is that the
momentum of a particle
is Gaussian distributed,
is automatically satisfied.
And in this ensemble, each
one of the momenta you can see
is independently distributed
according to this probability
distribution.
So somethings clearly
emerge much easier
in this perspective.
And if I were to look
at the normalization Z,
the normalization Z I
obtained by integrating over
the entirety of the phase space.
So I have to do the integration
over d cubed Pi d cubed qi.
Since this is the phase
space of identical particles,
we said we have to
normalize it by N factorial.
And I had this
factor of H to the 3N
to make things dimensionless.
I have to exponentiate this
energy sum over i Pi squared
over 2m and just ensure that
the qi are inside the box.
So if I integrate the
qi, what do I get?
I will get V per particle.
So I have V to the N
divided by N factorial.
So that's the
volume contribution.
And then what are
the P integrations?
Each one of the P integrations
is an independent Gaussian.
In fact, each component
is independent.
So I have 3N Gaussian
integrations.
And I can do Gaussian
I will get root 2 pi
m inverse of beta,
which is kT per
Gaussian integration.
And there are 3N of them.
And, oh, I had the
factor of h to the 3N.
I will put it here.
So I chose these H's in order
to make this phase space
dimensionless.
So the Z that I have
now is dimensionless.
So the dimensions
of V must be made up
by dimensions of all of
these things that are left.
So I'm going to make that
explicitly clear by writing it
as 1 over N factorial V over
some characteristic volume
raised to the N-th power.
The characteristic volume comes
entirely from these factors.
So I have introduced
lambda of T,
which is h over root 2 pi mkT,
which is the thermal de Broglie
wavelength.
At this stage, this
h is just anything
to make things
dimensionally work.
When we do quantum
mechanics, we will
see that this lens scale
has a very important
physical meaning.
As long as the separations
of particles on average
is larger than this, you can
ignore quantum mechanics.
When it becomes
less than this, you
have to include quantum factors.
So then what do we have?
We have that the free
energy is minus kT log Z.
So F is minus kT log of
this partition function.
Log of that quantity will give
me N log V over lambda cubed.
Stirling's formula,
log of N factorial,
will give me N log N over e.
So that's the free energy.
Once I have the free energy,
I can calculate, let's say,
the volume.
Let's see, dF, which
is d of E minus TS,
is minus SdT minus
PdV, because work
of the gas we had
identified as minus PdV.
I have mu dN.
What do we have, therefore?
We have that, for example, P
is minus dF by dV at constant T
and N. So I have to go and
look at this expression
where the V up here, it
just appears in log V.
So the answer is going
to be NkT over V.
I can calculate the
chemical potential.
Mu will be dF by dN
at constant T and V,
so just take the derivative with
respect to N. So what do I get?
I will get minus kT log
of V over N lambda cubed.
And this E will
disappear when I take
the derivative with
respected to that log inside.
So that's the formula for my mu.
I won't calculate entropy.
But I will calculate the energy,
noting that in this ensemble,
a nice way of calculating energy
is minus d log Z by d beta.
So this is minus
d log Z by d beta.
And my Z, you can see, has
a bunch of things-- V, N, et
cetera.
But if I focus on temperature,
which is the inverse beta,
you can see it appears
with a factor of 3N over 2.
So this is beta to
the minus 3N over 2.
So this is going to be 3N
over 2 derivative of log beta
with respect to beta,
which is 1 over beta,
which is the same
thing as 3 over 2 NkT.
So what if I wanted to maintain
the system at some fixed
temperature, but
rather than telling you
what the volume of the
box is, I will tell you
what its pressure is and
how many particles I have?
How can I ensure that I
have a particular pressure?
You can imagine that this is
the box that contains my gas.
And I put a weight
on top of some kind
of a piston that can
move over the gas.
So then you would say
that the net energy that I
have to look at is the
kinetic energy of the gas
particles here plus
the potential energy
of this weight that
is going up and down.
If you like, that
potential energy
is going to be mass times delta
H. Delta H times area gives you
volume.
Mass times G divided by
area will give you pressure.
So the combination of
those two is the same thing
as pressure times volume.
So this is going to
be the same thing
as minus sum over i
Pi squared over 2m.
For all of the gas particles
for this additional weight that
is going up and
down, it will give me
a contribution that
is minus beta PV.
And so this is the
probability in this state.
It is going to be the
same as this provided
that I divide by some
Gibbs partition function.
So this is the probability
of the microstate.
So what is the Gibbs
partition function?
Well, what is the normalization?
I now have one
additional variable,
which is where this piston
is located in order to ensure
that it is at the
right pressure.
So I have to integrate also
over the additional volume.
This additional factor
only depends on PV.
And then I have
to integrate given
that I have some
particular V that I then
have to integrate over all
of the microstates that
are confined within this volume.
Their momenta and their
coordinates-- what is that?
I just calculated that.
That's the partition function
as a function of T, V, and N.
So for a fixed V, I
already did the integration
over all microscopic
degrees of freedom.
I have one more integration
to do over the volume.
And that's it.
So if you like, this is like
doing a Laplace transform.
To go from Z of T, V, and N,
to this Z tilde of T, P, and N
is making some kind of
a Laplace transformation
from one variable
to another variable.
And now I know
actually what my answer
was for the partition function.
It was 1 over N factorial
V over lambda cubed raised
to the power of N. So I have
1 over N factorial lambda
to the power of 3N.
And then I have to do
one of these integrals
that we have seen many times,
the integral of V to the N
against an exponential.
That's something
that actually we
used in order to define N
factorial, except that I have
to dimensionalize this V. So
I will get a factor of beta P
to the power of N plus 1.
The N factorials cancel.
And the answer is beta
P to the power of N
plus 1 divided by lambda
cubed to the power of N.
So my Gibbs free
energy, which is minus
kT log of the Gibbs
partition function,
is going to be minus
NkT log of this object.
I have ignored the difference
between N and N plus 1.
And what I will get here
is the combination beta
P lambda cubed.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is your
beta P to the N plus 1
in the numerator
or the denominator?
PROFESSOR: Thank you, it should
be in the denominator, which
means that-- OK,
this one is correct.
I guess this one I was
going by dimensions.
Because beta PV
is dimensionless.
All right, yes.
AUDIENCE: One other
thing, it seems
like there's a dimensional
mismatch in your expression
for Z. Because you have an
extra factor of beta P--
PROFESSOR: Exactly right,
because this object
is a probability density that
involves a factor of volume.
And as a probability density,
the dimension of this
will carry an extra
factor of volume.
So if I really wanted to make
this quantity dimensionless
also, I would need to
divide by something
that has some
dimension of volume.
But alternatively, I can
recognize that indeed this
is a probability
density in volume.
So it will have the
dimensions of volume.
And again, as I said,
what I'm really always
careful to make sure that is
dimensionless is the thing that
is proportional to N. If there's
a log of a single dimension
out here, typically we don't
have to worry about it.
But if you think
about its origin,
the origin is indeed
that this quantity
is a probability density.
But it will, believe
me, not change anything
in your life to ignore that.
All right, so once we have this
G, then we recognize-- again,
hopefully I didn't
make any mistakes.
G is E plus PV minus TS.
So dG should be minus
SdT plus VdP plus mu dN.
So that, for example, in this
ensemble I can ask-- well,
I told you what the pressure is.
What's the volume?
Volume is going to be
obtained as dG by dP
at constant
temperature and number.
So these two are constant.
Log P, its derivative is
going to give me NkT over P.
So again, I get another
form of the ideal gas
equation of state.
I can ask, what's the
chemical potential?
It is going to be dG by
dN at constant T and P.
So I go and look at
the N dependence.
And I notice that there's just
an N dependence out front.
So what I will get is kT
log of beta P lambda cubed.
And if you like, you
can check that, say,
this expression for
the chemical potential
and-- did we derive
it somewhere else?
Yes, we derived it over here.
This expression for
the chemical potential
are identical once you take
advantage of the ideal gas
equation of state
to convert the V
over N in that
expression to beta P.
And finally, we have
the grand canonical.
Let's do that also.
So now we are going to look at
an ensemble where I tell you
what the temperature is
and the chemical potential.
But I have to tell you
what the volume is.
And then the statement
is that the probability
of a particular microstate
that I will now indicate mu
s force system-- not to be
confused with the chemical
potential-- is proportional
to e to the beta mu
N minus beta H of the
microstate energy.
And the normalization is this Q,
which will be a grand partition
function that is
function of T, V, and mu.
How is this
probability normalized?
Well, I'm spanning over
a space of microstates
that have indefinite number.
Their number runs, presumably,
all the way from 0 to infinity.
And I have to multiply each
particular segment that
has N of these present
with e to the beta mu N.
Now, once I have that
segment, what I need to do
is to sum over all
coordinates and momenta
as appropriate to a
system of N particles.
And that, once more, is
my partition function
Z of T, V, and N. And so since
I know what that expression is,
I can substitute it in
some e to the beta mu
N. And Z is 1 over N factorial
V over lambda cubed raised
to the power of N.
Now fortunately, that's
a sum that I recognize.
It is 1 over N factorial
something raised
to the N-th power
summed over all N,
which is the summation
for the exponential.
So this is the exponential
of e to the beta mu
V over lambda cubed.
So once I have this,
I can construct
my G, which is minus kT
log of Q, which is minus
kT e to the beta mu V
divided by lambda cubed.
Now, note that in all
of the other expressions
that I had all of these logs of
something, they were extensive.
And the extensivity was
ensured by having results
that were ultimately
proportional
to N for these logs.
Let's say I have here,
I have an N here.
For the s, I have an N there.
Previously I had also an N here.
Now, in this
ensemble, I don't have
N. Extensivity is insured by
this thing being proportional
to G. Now also remember that
G was E minus TS minus mu N.
But we had another
result for extensivity,
that for extensive systems,
E was TS plus mu N minus PV.
So this is in fact
because of extensivity, we
had expected it to be
proportional to the volume.
And so this combination
should end up
being in fact the pressure.
I can see what the pressure
is in different ways.
I can, for example,
look at what this dG is.
It is minus SdT.
It is minus PdV minus Nd mu.
I could, for example,
identify the pressure
by taking a derivative of
this with respect to volume.
But it is proportional
to volume.
So I again get that
this combination really
should be pressure.
You say, I don't recognize
that as a pressure.
You say, well, it's because
the formula for pressure
that we have been using is
always in terms of N. So let's
check that.
So what is N?
I can get N from
minus dG by d mu.
And what happens if I do that?
When I take a derivative
with respect to mu,
I will bring down
a factor of beta.
Beta will kill the kT.
I will get e to the beta mu
V over lambda cubed, which
by the way is also
these expressions
that we had previously for
the relationship between mu
and N over V lambda
cubed if I just
take the log of this expression.
And then if I substitute e to
the beta mu V over lambda cubed
to BN, you can see that I have
the thing that I was calling
pressure is indeed NkT
over V. So everything
is consistent with
the ideal gas law.
The chemical potential comes
out consistently-- extensivity,
everything is
correctly identified.
Maybe one more thing
that I note here
is that, for this ideal gas
and this particular form that I
have for this object-- so
let's maybe do something here.
Note that the N appears
in an exponential with e
to the beta mu.
So another way that I
could have gotten my N
would have been d log Q
with respect to beta mu.
And again, my log Q is
simply V over lambda cubed
e to the beta mu.
And you can check
that if I do that, I
will get this formula
that I had for N. Well,
the thing is that I can
get various cumulants
of this object by continuing
to take derivatives.
So I take m derivatives of log
of Q with respect to beta mu.
So I have to keep taking
derivatives of the exponential.
And as long as I keep taking the
derivative of the exponential,
I will get the exponential back.
So all of these things
are really the same thing.
So all cumulants of the
number fluctuations of the gas
are really the same
thing as a number.
Can you remember what that says?
What's the distribution?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Poisson, very good.
The distribution where all of
the cumulants were the same
is Poisson distribution.
Essentially it says
that if I take a box,
or if I just look at that
imaginary volume in this room,
and count the
number of particles,
as long as it is
almost identical,
the distribution of the number
of particles within the volume
is Poisson.
You know all of the
fluctuations, et cetera.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So this
expression, you
have N equals e to the beta mu V
divided by lambda to the third.
Considering that
expression, could you then
say that the exponential
quantity is proportional
to the phase space
density [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Let's rearrange this.
Beta mu is log of N
over V lambda cubed.
This is a single
particle density.
So beta mu, or the chemical
potential up to a factor of kT,
is the log of how many particles
fit within one de Broglie
volume.
And this expression is in
fact correct only in the limit
where this is small.
And as we shall
see later on, there
will be quantum
mechanical corrections
when this combination is large.
So this combination is very
important in identifying
when things become
quantum mechanic.
All right, so let's
just give a preamble
of what we will be
doing next time.
I should have erased
the [INAUDIBLE].
So we want to now do
interacting systems.
So this one example
of the ideal gas I
did for you to [INAUDIBLE]
in all possible ensembles.
And I could do
that, because it was
a collection of non-interacting
degrees of freedom.
As soon as I have interactions
among my huge number of degrees
of freedom, the story changes.
So let's, for example, look
at a generalization of what
I had written before-- a one
particle description which
if I stop here gives me an
ideal system, and potentially
some complicated interaction
among all of these coordinates.
This could be a
pairwise interaction.
It could have three particles.
It could potentially--
at this stage
I want to write down
the most general form.
I want to see what I can
learn about the properties
of this modified version,
or non-ideal gas,
and the ensemble that I
will choose initially.
Microcanonical is
typically difficult.
I will go and do
things canonically,
which is somewhat easier.
And later on, maybe even
grand canonical is easier.
So what do I have to do?
I would say that the
partition function is obtained
by integrating over the entirety
of this phase space-- product
d cubed Pi d cubed qi.
I will normalize
things by N factorial,
dimensionalize them
by h to the 3N.
And I have exponential
of minus beta
sum over i Pi squared over 2m.
And then I have the
exponential of minus U.
Now, this time around, the
P integrals are [INAUDIBLE].
I can do them immediately.
Because typically the momenta
don't interact with each other.
And practicality, no
matter how complicated
a system of interactions
is, you will
be able to integrate over the
momentum degrees of freedom.
And what you get, you
will get this factor of 1
over lambda to the power
of 3N from the 3N momentum
integrations.
The thing that is hard-- there
will be this factor of 1 over N
factorial-- is the integration
over all of the coordinates,
d cubed qi of this factor
of e to the minus beta
U. I gave you the most general
possible U. There's no way
that I can do this integration.
What I will do is I will divide
each one of these integrations
over coordinate of
particle by its volume.
I will therefore
have V to the N here.
And V to the N divided by
lambda to the 3N N factorial
is none other than
the partition function
that we had calculated
before for the ideal gas.
And I will call Z0
for the ideal gas.
And I claim that this
object I can interpret
as a kind of average
of a function e
to the beta U defined over
the phase space of all
of these particles
where the probability
to find each particle is
uniform in the space of the box,
let's say.
So what this says is
for the 0-th order case,
for the ideal case that we
have discussed, once I have set
the box, the particle can be
anywhere in the box uniformly.
For that uniform
description probability,
calculate what the average
of this quantity is.
So what we have is that
Z is in fact Z0, that
average that I can expand.
And what we will
be doing henceforth
is a perturbation
theory in powers of U.
Because I know how to do things
for the case of U equals 0.
And then I hope to calculate
things in various powers of U.
So I will do that expansion.
And then I say, no
really, what I'm
interested in is something like
a free energy, which is log Z.
And so for that, I will need log
of Z0 plus log of that series.
But the log of these
kinds of series
I know I can write as
minus beta to the l over l
factorial, replacing, when
I go to the log, moments
by corresponding cumulants.
So this is called the
cumulant expansion,
which we will carry
out next time around.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In
general, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: For some
cases, you can.
For many cases,
you find that that
will give you wrong answers.
Because the phase space
around which you're expanding
is so broad.
It is not like a
saddle point where
you have one variable
you are expanding
in a huge number of variables.